With summer sun rays, you wanna take extra care of your skin.
From sunscreen application tips to key ingredients,...
...you can find the best products to protect your skin this season.
Hi guys, I'm Krystin Goodwin with Buzz60,...
...and here are a few helpful reminders and tricks...
...to protect your skin without skipping a beat.
Choose a broad spectrum sunscreen with UVB and UVA protection.
This will protect against burns and other skin damage.
Make sure to apply sunscreen in the shade or at home 15 minutes...
...before going in the sun to allow it to set.
For your lips, use an SPF 30 balm.
Do not use lip gloss.
Gloss intensifies sun exposure and the effects of UV rays.
It's like baby oil on your lips.
To avoid watery eyes, use sunscreen with zinc oxide on your face.
This will reduce the irritation to the skin and the eyes .
While waterproof or sweatproof sunscreens are helpful, you will still need to reapply.
Be sure to bring a bottle along for touch-ups and reapply every two to three hours.
So protect your skin from head to toe this season.
With the right skin care products, you can keep calm and put that sunscreen on.
Buzz60, now you know, pass it on.